he could just go hook tup with this
chick on tinder and like what's gonna
happen like at what point of people
gonna stop being completely befuddled
that he said something stupid and yeah
that's that's that's simple [ __ ] Sue's
touching an undercover cop was it she
was touching on the cover cop or she
allowed the undercover cop to touch her
I believe that but what I read from her
attorney last night on Twitter is that
she this is the same show or whatever a
performance she's been doing all over
the country it's like it's what she does
she was gonna do it hmm so is almost a
setup or something
she wasn't blowing a guy in a [ __ ]
you know the the champagne room or
something I thought when you read the
law it said the law was that you can't
touch someone in an adult establishment
unless it's a family member that's the
[ __ ] law whoa so like you walked over
to Jamie and rub his back you go to jail
unless we're related we haven't done a
23mm we who regularly appears nude or
semi-nude a sexually oriented business
is prohibited from touching patrons
except for family members huh so there
goes the charges were dismissed
according to court documents I wonder if
it was like our rogue cop who's like a
[ __ ] Trump fan who's like [ __ ] dudes
Booch absolutely do it for Donald yeah
yeah it can absolutely that's like
that's not a well-thought well-oiled
plan by the white house that's a plan by
one [ __ ] Yahoo with three different
maggots at home you know [ __ ] thorn
in his shoe this [ __ ] she think she's
gonna take down POTUS it's my favorite
when they call him POTUS you know like
they like whiff POTUS did this like come
on it's Trump
that's Trump we got to stop yeah that's
a laugh that's one syllable not only
that it's like
this is what got us here in the first
place Daniel's remove what okay in
probation affidavit obtained by CNN
detectives who are at the sirens
gentlemen's club said they observed
Daniels remove her top and force patrons
face into her chest force yeah well
she's a monster hey I wasn't here for
this yeah it's not like she did that to
a trained killer with a gun to a cop
it's not even a regular guy it's a guy
who makes his living stopping crime and
she's not being fun and he's a vice cop
but he can't even stop at it plunge like
she forced him in there there's nothing
he could do about it was basically rape
nothing he could do yeah he couldn't go
hey stop another me too
when officers witnessed those activities
three detective approaches staged
Daniels allegedly made her way towards
the two detectives leaned over and
grabbed their faces she shoved each of
their faces between her breasts court
documents said faced with her breasts
they they I can't believe that she
fondled a 3rd officers buttocks and
breasts according to the document and
then forced the officers head between
her breasts and smacked the officers
face with her breasts
if you imagine arresting somebody for
that you [ __ ] lazy civil servant
leech you leech you there's money that
could have gone to schools his money
could have gone to fixed streets money
could have gone to all sorts of good
things in the community but you leached
it you [ __ ] snail just creeped over
got that lady to touch you and arrested
her whoa
well I did get six thousand dollars bail
yeah but she the charges already
dismissed doesn't she get that money
back yep I think so yeah it's ridiculous
it's [ __ ] ridiculous that's the thing
what you're saying but this is cops some
of them are awesome some of them are
awesome and just get a certain small
percentage of them they're ruin it for
everybody it doesn't even have to be 1%
but if one percent of cops is out there
shooting kids
I mean it's less than that because it's
it's less than it's not even every day
a cop doing something [ __ ] up is
usually once a week
figure [ __ ] millions of interactions
these cops have with people I mean every
day something's going wrong all over the
country someone's pulling someone over
that has a gun someone's pulling
something someone over that hasn't
expired license or stolen property or
they're just constantly dealing with
people it's amazing I think there's an
argument in hey the cops should live in
the communities policing yes